is your life being correct by the
super-rich the super-rich who are they
and what are they doing to us what are
they doing to us whatever it is people
say that just the fact that the rich
have so much is itself immoral immoral
and wrong that the top one-tenth of 1%
in this country and almost as much
wealth as the bottom 90% is that any
moral outcome they want to condemn the
people that actually have moved
civilization forward Iran Brooke of the
Iran Institute's annoyed that today's
Democratic socialists say rich people
got rich by taking money from others in
fact they actually improved the standard
of living for everybody in the planet
how is that possible how could it
improve everyone's living standard isn't
there a fixed amount of money in the
world so when rich people grab a lot
there's less for everyone else
no because wealth can be created we have
basically made about $2 a day for a
hundred thousand years in other words we
could eat what we what we farmed and
that was it and then something amazing
happened about two hundred and fifty
years ago a few countries tried
capitalism for the first time people
were allowed to profit from private
property that changed everything
division of labor let people produce
more with less and then they traded to
get even more wealth increased with
every innovation cargo transported by
ship he used to be stored in barrels in
sacks in wooden crates and offloaded by
hand economists on boudreaux points out
that enormous wealth was even created by
the invention of the shipping container
with it came a wave of specialized
technology that dramatically increased
the productivity of shipping workers
today are superhuman compared to their
brethren of yesteryear we went from
carrying bags in our backs to lifting
the equivalent of two school buses with
mere flicks of our wrists most of this
innovation began just 250 years ago 250
years ago we suddenly discovered the
value of individual freedom we suddenly
discovered the value of leaving
individuals free to think to innovate to
produce without asking for permission
without getting the state to sign off on
it and we call that the Industrial
Revolution industrialists the people who
owned the factories employed hundreds
sometimes thousands of people and they
made enormous profit and how does that
benefit your fellow man and ever since
politicians have complained about those
profits in Iran's novel Atlas Shrugged
state officials demand that
industrialists explain how they're
getting rich helped others I do not owe
you an answer but I could tell you in a
hundred ways thousands of jobs billions
in revenue fueling our economy despite
your efforts Hank Rearden was right
capitalism created new wealth we got
much much much richer and it's hard to
imagine how much richer we got
electricity of running water the things
we all take for granted today but we
didn't have 150 years ago and yes some
people complain about inequality but
everybody got richer even the poor got
richer in the past several hundred years
we've gone from a society where people
hope to get jobs that required long
hours of hard manual labor to one where
almost everyone has what they need to
live and more people have leisure time
to do things like watch movies
you're a wizard Harry I mentioned Harry
Potter because Brooke bought lots of
Harry Potter books but he says he's not
poorer for it
jakie Rollins became a billionaire and I
got poorer by thousands of dollars and
yet nobody really thinks of themselves
as poorer for having read Harry Potter
it made my kids happy how much is that
worth so I am actually better off for
having spent those many dollars on those
books under capitalism that applies to
every transaction because capitalism
unlike socialism is voluntary like a
pretzel we see this every time we buy
something the sellers there for his own
self-interest and so am I so why do we
both say hey thank you thank you because
he wanted the dollar more than he wanted
the pretzel I wanted the pretzel more
than the dollar the transaction doesn't
happen unless both of us think we win
and that way voluntary transactions
create wealth thank you thank you since
the Industrial Revolution we have more
than doubled our life expectancy we have
dramatically increased the quality of
our life and we are wealthier than
anybody could have imagined made
possible by private property and
capitalism which people hate people
don't like it because you know it takes
real responsibility over your own life
to achieve something and unfortunately
our educational system has taught us
that since we don't sacrifice enough
because we're we're basically too
self-interested to sacrifice enough the
statements now intervene and force us to
sacrifice our fellow man and that belief
that sacrificing for others is more
moral is what gives socialism strength
it's not so tough to share your stuff
every priest every philosopher every
mother has taught us that to be selfless
is good selfless is good no mother
actually means that right she no mother
actually wants you to be last in line
they all want you to be first in line
but they tell you that because they
think that's what nobility is but the
people who do for others are not more
model because they're wasting the one
life that they have lots of us see
morality as
thing other people if your house burned
down
neighbors in America have always helped
their neighbors what I'd like you
Objectivist didn't approve of that Iran
was never against charity what she said
was that that was not the major virtue
in life and that you should voluntarily
have a choice about who you help and who
you don't the key is that somebody
else's need is not a mall claim against
your life your life is yours today
socialists say self-absorbed Americans
won't help the poor and the sick
that's why government must force
everyone to give otherwise the weak and
the poor will suffer and die but indeed
the weak in the poor under capitalism
has done better than in any other system
is a fantastic system that is
fundamentally modeled because it allows
individuals to pursue their own
happiness your pursuit of your own
well-being which is a virtue in and of
itself also helps the world be a better
world